good morning John this video out of
necessity has some swear words in it
though they're all bleak but if you're
ultra-sensitive to that kind of thing
you may just not want to watch this one
you hopefully remember in my last video
that I said in front of some little kids
at the mall and I felt like a huge that
got me wondering what the are swear
words anyway so those are all the
definitions and every one of them so I
created my own and that is it's a word
that you know how to say and you know
what it means but you know also not to
say it in front of your mom
also the word cannot slander any
particular group of people because a
slur is different than a swear sometimes
the curse word will make a transition
from curse word to slander and that's
why the word remains at the top of most
people's do not say list because it's
not just a swear word it's also become
slander of like half of the world's
population it's easy to say like I did
at the beginning this video there's
nothing special about dirt but that's
actually literally not true there is
something different about them swear
words have a different kind of power
than normal words for example people who
in a scientific study were being
subjected to pain I know science it's so
much fun who would stand more pain when
they were encouraged to swear yeah next
to me subito is actually a perfectly
legitimate and like probably a good idea
to discrete up swear words have power
because we'd give them power of course
it's unclear why we ascribe the power of
profanity to some words and not to other
words definitely a linguistic form
that's more common if it has a round
noise in the middle at a hard noise at
the end they're almost always words for
things that we're ashamed of like body
parts or sex or bodily functions one so
it becomes a curse it loses its original
meaning pretty fast like I'm not talking
about any particular sphincter when I
call someone it's almost as if my brain
is a special place for curse words
that's different from the place where it
stores normal words for tea it does
language and linguistics happen and a
recently developed and very complex part
of the brain in the left hemisphere
swearing on the other hand happens in
the emotional bit in the limbic system
swear words are stored and accessed in a
completely different way so next time
you think there's nothing different
about swear words there is there
physiologically different for us this is
why it's hard not to scream when you die
on the last boss and Super Mario
Brothers we you can think of swear words
is being stored in our brains as units
of emotional expression almost like a
laugh or a scream or crying it's it
blurs the line between linguistics and
emotion in this way it's actually
possible that swearing gives us insights
into the origin of language the first
words ever spoken by an cest
of Homo sapiens may have found their
home in the same place that we now store
our Tintin so check this out we call
them curse words and we don't think
about that but what we're saying here is
that they're magic because I think deep
down we always knew that words are magic
and some words have more power than
other all the words that I have said in
this video is a spell that I'm casting
upon your brain
we could build worlds with words we can
tear worlds down language is the tool
that all of this wonderful stuff that
I'm surrounded by is built on it's the
one tool over any other that created
humanity and it's just so beautiful John
I'll see you on Monday oh I have a
mustache hey there ladies I'm Hank green
I have a mustache now I don't look like
anything like me do i completely
different dude also and have got a
haircut in the last couple hours so
everything is just different I did a
whole video of me shaving it I'm gonna
put the whole thing up on Hanks channel
I don't feel like I look like a
pedophile kind of look like a cop I'm
Hank the cop what are you got in your
truck what's in your truck open up your
trunk that's what cops do right they
tell you to open your trunk man that is
not me that isn't I'm not that guy as
long as you here let me see about the
new YouTube it allows you to go through
your subscriptions and tax certain
people in your top ten unfortunately if
you have 10 people vlogbrothers will
still be a below the fold because our
name starts with a V so you should only
tak 5 people ok dftba and officer Hank
says don't do drugs